hey guys I'm Ryan right Alyssa be crazy
we're gonna watch a trailer day for a
movie called American sniper this is a
film that stars Bradley Cooper I like
him I like Bradley Cooper a lot yeah he
was great in silver linings playbook
loved him in limitless he was also great
in a movie he recently did Rocket
Raccoon and guardians of the galaxy he
yes that's what it was so ya know
Bradley Cooper he's the [ __ ] I used to
hate Bradley Cooper why I remember the
first thing I ever saw man was wedding
crashers not a alias he was such an
[ __ ] in that movie I remember that he
was he was like the antagonist for a
long time I couldn't like him because I
thought he was such a genuine [ __ ] I
mean he did a great job because like now
he's like totally likable and everything
so ya know Bradley Cooper's a [ __ ]
anyway I don't anything about this movie
I'm assuming it's about some sniper so
yeah let's check this [ __ ] out all right
I got military-age male on the cell
phone watching the convoy over thank you
reporting yeah maybe just call his old
lady oh look at those bugs and is it
armed
please don't know
hold on I got a woman and a kid to our
yards out moving towards the convoy
oh no way her on Laurens wagon she's
carrying something
and she's got her nighties get RKG
Russian grenade kid you see a woman in a
kid yeah that was on this can you
confirm negative you're called Oh mmm
they fry you if you're wrong
hi hi Brian
hurry arms yeah oh that was really
intense that was uh looks really
chilling you know like you really seems
to capture the fear and like holy crap I
didn't realize how much decision-making
they live up to the sniper I thought he
just followed orders I didn't realize
that like like no you decided we're
gonna shoot the kid or not and it's your
choice you recall that looks like a
horrible job I'll watch the movie just
to see if he shoots that kid which I
hope he does because he was about to
blow up [ __ ] okay if the kid's gonna
blow up things you gotta shoot the
little [ __ ] it goes it's yeah his
family is like being held hostage or
something he doesn't actually want to do
it
what if he's being forced to do it it's
not the kids fault so let the kid kill a
bunch of people or kill one kid and save
the lives of a lot of people ah that's
the decision
Bradley Cooper has to make damn good
movie get to thinking cuz it's like
inclining to this it's a clever trailer
because now you people are gonna debate
whether or not he should shoot the kid
which is the debate he's having back and
forth but they really gave you like a
scene and even though it was like almost
a full scene there were no spoilers
yeah they don't reveal if he shoots a
kid and I that that is a very much of a
life decision moment right there so
really in you know like you could tell
like he's just thinking like this
decision determines the rest of my
future right now it's terrified yes and
I know Clint Eastwood hasn't been making
the greatest of films lately but this
looks like nah he still he still got the
magic touch Wow things magic touch ever
went away you might have been saving it
for something like this we did like
three movies in a row that no one really
cared for this is all I'm saying
or to movies can't remember Bradley
Cooper man I mean just he looks like
he's turning in a powerful yet subtle
performance you know like that's that's
great I hope he gets nominated I haven't
even seen the movie but I hope he gets
nominated for this movie hey you know I
know I'm a little late to the to the
Bradley Cooper train but I actually just
saw silver linings playbook like three
days ago mm-hmm great me like even more
of course he got a nomination for that
yeah yeah he's fantastic he's a great
actor I mean the combination of a
starring like dramatic performance from
Bradley Cooper and directed by Clint
Eastwood I hope it's good because when I
heard DiCaprio and Eastwood were working
together I was like this movie's gonna
be perfect and it was not so I'm hoping
that this one totally delivers it's a
great trailer and it looks like it
really has the tension there it did yeah
yeah it does like when all the hairs on
your arm stand up like totally straight
like there's no doubting that it's not
at least going to be chilling you know
it's weird is like something of mine
stood up totally straight up it wasn't
the hair of my arms
there's my penis my penis something
about the sniper shooting the kid got my
you're a terrible person anyway guys
ever near the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects and alyssa has a
channel called Alyssa be crazy you can
type it in as one word or you could type
it in as three separate words it's it's
way more you know well the URL is one
but I'm saying it to type it on YouTube
like if they if they just have an Elissa
space be space crazy you'll still come
up really yeah good to know
unmonitored the other rejects channel I
just sit at my computer
hahahahaha grow your chance
James Stevens my shoutout was on your
deleted whiplash trailer reaction thank
you and keep up the great work
yeah you know what man since its deleted
the video yes I will redeem you with
another shout-out detective James
Stevens work for the FBI wait
yeah that's detective FBI yeah that
makes sense
Special Agent James Stevens much better
4:00 in the morning still working on the
goddamn case and then she walks in
justice never sleeps yo I was I was
going like film noir I was about to
introduce a lady and that you can sure
that you're gonna row me thank you thank
you interrupt me do you think the
moments cause she's standing there the
moments gone standing there moments ago
understand there I was gonna describe
her I was gonna describe her like a film
noir type of thing and it was gonna be
hilarious
but now the hilarity is gone
congratulations Alissa you have [ __ ]
up the joke sorry James
Larry's Stambaugh as usual you guys keep
putting out great reaction videos keep
up the good work I'm a huge fan if you
could give me a shout-out that would be
awesome
real rejects for life Larry stambha it's
totally a Jewish person necessarily I
want I want to know if you're Jewish
not just Larry any of you comment below
I have to find out how many Jewish
subscribers I have you know what I think
would be really interesting is if each
person commented what country they're
from but mainly the Jews is what we're
looking for here you can go on her
Channel and list your countries you know
primarily looking for Jews right now
Larry
gather your Jews it is time for the Jews
to meet Ryan right we're gonna go out
gonna have a bum it's left or whatever
you guys do to celebrate la la la mr.
Lall cakes damn it Ryan I complimented
you I don't get a shout out you're no
longer my lover
oh and shout-out mr. Lall cakes dude
come on
you know we're still lovers come on baby
after every session that's what I call
them sessions ah he - he that's why it's
okay you know cuz like guys are always
like I don't care if my girl makes out
with another girl and I think the same
probably applies vice versa
so if I'm making out with mr. Lall cakes
it's okay
have you talked to your miss about this
she doesn't even know it's just a guy
you may want to clarify these things
before you do them dude but mr. law
cakes is really good at what he does I
don't even have to do anything to him
tell him I wanna clarify just just make
100% wasn't it in case you guys are on
mr. law cases he is a 5 foot 11
african-american gentleman with a little
bit of Chinese blood um he is incredibly
good at volleyball but sucks at
basketball love's wear red converse
loves to wear red converse yeah um is
also Jewish he tends to wear his
yarmulke wherever he goes and he's a
huge Star Wars fan
he's a african-american Jew a tall
African American Jew who's really into
Star Wars